hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from round six of the
Phaedo World Team Championship it's
England versus Iran this is board for we
have John Spielman versus ali reza phir
aaja and I don't know some of you may
know George Pillman some of you may not
those of you who are older definitely
know of him now he is 62 years of age
but in some 1989 he was ranked among the
top five chess players in the world
maybe even the top four I was a part of
Karpov then maybe short and then George
Pillman with belly oski and Yvonne took
somewhere you know very near but
definitely a strong player he wrote
several chess books most of them on on
the endgame so definitely a stronger
opponent for for a young Iranian
Grandmaster so without further ado let's
check out the game but before that we do
have some nice photos all of them
compliments of David Lada who is the
official photographer of the event there
you have it and an excellent photo of
John Spielman very nicely very nicely
done and also we have a very nice photo
of both viraja and world junior champion
par hammock Sulu who is playing board
one for Iran yeah you know just just a
monster chess player having an
excellence tournament but okay was maybe
in today's joust against England that he
faced his first bump in the road but
we're gonna talk a bit more about the
results after and I don't know if I
mentioned George Pillman was qualified
twice for the candidates tournament once
first time he qualified he was kicked
out by intamin and then second time he
qualified he was kicked out by by Nigel
short barking and also I sent Lada your
regards that you demand the more photos
of Alexander agree shook so there you
have it a very nice photo of Sasha so
it's just enjoyed that for a moment you
know if you think about it the Sasha
Sasha is somewhat like like Barney from
How I Met Your Mother you know it's just
not possible for him to take a bad photo
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna put it out
there now but yeah now really without
further ado let's check out the game our
filming with the white pieces opens with
knife to f3 the reti opening we have
nitrous
by Alireza g3 g6 and now just b3
preparing to fianchetto the other bishop
as well
we have d5 Bishop to b2 and c5 so nurse
woman going for some hyper modern
development and all arrays are just you
know place it principally grabs the
center with the pawns that which of
course makes sense push up to g2 Bishop
to g7 and both players Castle and here
III we have rook to e8 by holidays and
already this is only move 7 we have a
completely new game that has not been
reached before the Forbush Pillman we
have seek after some d4 and now ii
capture Sundy for Bishop capture
somebody for seems like wiser decision
which the idea that you do want your
Bishop - you know remain very active but
this way your opponent's official will
be very active as well and white has
white has a different plan he plays it
captures now he has a lot of control of
the e5 square as you can see so perhaps
even the knight can find an outpost
there and if not you know it's just a
very strong position for white with the
with the black rook on e8 black will
have some trouble performing a5 with
Bishop to f5 from black and then now
comes c4 again a principled decision you
don't want your opponent to remain a
backwards pawn and c2 so you do want to
advance it as far as possible D captures
on c4 big factors on c4 and now just
Knight to c6 oh it has a continuous
development the position pretty much is
asking for d5 which is of course
playable but then after night before you
can see the knight and the bishop are
you know very harmoniously working
together maybe night - d3 is an idea so
not not a lot of problems for black here
so instead after Knight to c6 we have
Queen to b3 by Stillman going after the
b7 pawn but here you have a problem here
furuse that goes Knight to a5 and now he
still moans Queen is under attack and
also the c4 pawn is under attack so you
can defend the pawn either by will going
Queen to b4 or you can go Queen to c3
quinta c3 is really a
interests move you have to see really
really far ahead and it's not all that
easy if if Quintus III was played Luke
the c8 still going after the c4 pawn now
comes tonight f2 d2 defending and now
that the knight has moved Knight to e4
and just attacking the Queen and also
the night here Knight captures Bishop
captures Bishop captures a temporary
peace sacrifice and now just Knight
captures in c4 and now of course the
threat is capturing the bishop and then
picking up the d4 pawn or which would
come with an attack against the Queen
and the rook on a one that is undefended
so you do have to play Knights that you
can't move the bishop if you move the
bishop then just a bunch of characters
here will be deadly
so Knight 283 you have to make the rook
on a1 defended Knight captures Queen
captures not just Bishop captures on d4
Queen captures on b7 and now after not
capturing media the first rook to b8
attacking the Queen Queen d5 and not
just the shock captures rook captures
and we would get this position where
black is up upon but White has a knight
and a bishop for a rook so mmm white
white is the P to be preferred here but
it's like I said an adventurous move
this Queen to C 3 so here Spillman
played Queen to b4 he keeps an eye on
the c4 pawn but now well this just
blunders upon and I'm sure you all see
why white wanders upon if not I'll give
you a second you don't have to pause the
video or anything just you know enjoy
the position for a bit you can see that
the queen is defending the knight so
there are no problems there but just
Bishop to d3 comes with an attack on the
rook and under c4 pawn and this is the
problem after loop the c1 which no doubt
Spielman saw a feud or is it just play
Bishop captures on c4 and now there's a
problem you cannot capture rook captures
on c4 because nice the d5 comes with an
attack on the Queen and you do have to
keep an eye on the rook you can't go to
b3 you can go to c3 you have to go to a
4 and now not nice to be 6 because then
you block the defense of your night
but first b5 this is the problem white
will face if if the if this
played when captures now rook to b8
notice that the bishopman b2 is also you
know feeling the pressure
Queen a4 and only now Knight captures in
c4 Queen captures and now after that the
bishop is no longer defended rook
captures here and you get this position
where black is just completely winning
up the exchange okay five phones each
but up the exchange would be a winning
position for black so after Bishop
captures on c4 Skillman saw that it was
not possible to grab the bishop
he just went Knight B to d2 sorry night
to d2 attacking the bishop on c4 and
sorry the other night goes to d2 and now
just Bishop to d5 so it's a clean pawn
and white it doesn't really have
anything to show for it
Knight to b3 now trying to exchange it a
night for a night so perhaps the Queen
can also pressure some of the Queen side
but not really for now the threat is
Knight captures night so Knight to c6
comes with an attack on the Queen and
even though the knight blocks the Bishop
defense of the b7 pawn it is not
possible to capture here because Knight
captures d4 opens up an attack against
the white queen and also there's a
double attack against the knight on f3
so here
after we move the Queen you just lose
the game you would captures with Charak
captures captures you're you're down a
piece so after Knight to c6 we have
Queen to be five but Spillman and now
Ali Reza just pushes the Queen further
back a six we have Queen back to e2 and
now comes the shot to h6 this Bishop is
now assuming this well diagonal from
where the bishop will be much more
active also it forces the whites to
waste a move deciding what to do with
the rook we have looked a d1 and now
Queen to b6 developing the Queen but
also preparing 'if I've soaked with
Knight to c5 by white and now
well this even invites 'if I've because
now you will not be able to even capture
as the knight and c5 is hanging with
Queen to c2 now the queen is defending
the knight white is able to capture now
but the first black captures with pawn
captures Knight captures Bishop captures
and g2 King captures and g2 and now
Knight captures on d4
Bishop captures on d4 now aligning the
bishop with the Queen but here black
face white faces faces problems it seems
that the white is still doing perfectly
fine he's just down on down a pawn but
here's where things get really crazy
black uses this well exposed position of
the White King to remain over the Queen
the c6 we have Queen to c6 check which
aligns the black queen with the white
queen and notice that the Queen and c2
is undefended so white King has to move
we have King to g1 and now you can't win
a piece with b6 immediately because here
white can just capture on f6 after a
queen captures you you can just move the
knight and everything is fine for white
there is a there's a better plan after
King to g1 here black played Knight to
e4 first getting the knight out of f6 so
Bishop captures and f6 is no longer an
option
and now the night is under attack and
there of course the b6 could be a threat
bishop to the bishop to f8 is coming
roof to see it is coming there are so
many ways in which you can attack this
knight on c6 and the Queen here is still
undefended and of course you cannot go
up to c1 because the bishop still
controls the c1 squared but here's where
things get really interesting there is
one line that is so amazing that I'm
just gonna show it even though it wasn't
played if white goes f4 blocking the
bishop and preparing rook to c1 you
still can't win any anything here would
be 6 because of Queen to a4 notice that
the black Queen is undefended as well so
here you can't capture the night because
Queen captures Queen
so here you would have to go b5 and
after the Queen moves back now you go
Bishop to f8 again attacking the pin
piece or in this case pinning the attack
piece but then rook ate the c1 just
defending and here's where things get
really interesting Knight captures
Bishop captures and now of course you
see the move you can see that the queen
is controlling g2 rook to e2 now the
queen is threatening checkmate and there
is very little white can do here to
prevent checkmate white has to go Bishop
to f2 completely crazy position blocking
checkmate and opening up and
against the black queen and now comes
the craziest move Queen to h1 you just
have to remove the defender of the
Bishop on f2 King captures now you
capture the Queen while attacking the
rook and c1 and now the white rook and
the bishop are under attack the only way
to save both of them is to attack the
black Bishop black responds with b4
defenses of the ship and attacks the
rook and now comes Luke to f3 defending
the bishop and now just a rook captures
an a2 grabs a pawn and black with two
extra pawns well to connect the past
points on the Queen side I will have a
winning position but it's just just an
amazing position first that rook - E -
and then Queen - Queen - h1 check a
temporary Queen sacrifice just you know
beautiful but okay it was not played in
the game but I just wanted you to see
you know how poisonous the position was
after this night the night Stewie for we
have Knight captures on e4 Queen
captures on c2 now we have Knight to f6
check so instead of going through all of
this and trying to save something after
this night Stewie for white just decided
to give up the Queen
so Knight captures on e4 we have Queen
captures on c2 and now comes a fierce
attack from White Knight to f6 check so
here of course you don't want to go
under the mask of the Bishop team to f8
and now you can either capture on h7 or
do something else but one thing you
can't afford is to give white time you
know to create some sort of an attack or
to get or that's what the black doesn't
wanna do and why doesn't want to give
black the chance to consolidate if you
capture the h7 pawn then you can go King
g7 let's say Bishop to f6 check King t6
and now you don't have a good way of
continuing the attack you know you can't
bring this rook over to e1 and well if
rook to e1 check you can just hide in
the Kings side h3 if you prepare g4 just
rook captures rook captures and g5 you
create more room for King on g6 and the
black will escape so what's the other
thing you can do
oh here's Pillman try denied
d7 check and okay if you go back we're
just gonna repeat moose so you can go
back you have to go in the center of the
board we have King to e7
now comes the ship the c5 check forcing
black to move we have King to e6 and now
rook the d6 check bringing the King
deeper into the position we have King to
f5 and now it's interesting you can
either choose well what was played in
the game but you could also try a rook
to have six check for example King G for
now King G 2 and it looks deadly it
looks like black is getting checkmate is
for sure but the the the you know the
thing is he's really not for example
rook a to d8 black just prepares the
eliminated this night the night will be
a powerful attacker if you could switch
this Knight over to f6 then black really
would be in trouble but here even after
h3 check King h5
you don't really gain anything with g4
for example if rook captures making room
for the knight black will just eliminate
the night and there's there's no no more
attack going on at all so here after
King to a5 filmin tried worked the d5
check King to g4 and now rook a to d1
just doubling up here preparing rook to
d4 but I mean it would be nice if this
would come with check for example let's
say let's say black made a silly mood
then comes a rough check maybe King h3
and then work to h4 could end in
checkmate but here the problem is black
just played King to h3 and now there are
there are no more possibilities here
because rook to d4 sorry rook to d4 does
not come with check if you play rook to
d4 then rook e1 will be checkmate and
whatever black plays the or whatever
white plays doesn't really make any
difference because here it's actually
black who threatens checkmate you can
easily imagine Queen to b4 followed by
g2 and it's amazing to see that the king
is actually participating in this attack
so actively King is one of the one of
the mating pieces so here you could
let's say you want to prevent Queenie
for you could go its are hard to even
imagine you
Knight of six prevent 24 but then just
Queenie to again you can either go Queen
f3 and deliver checkmate on g2 or even
if black prevents that then you just the
good you know old-fashioned Queenie one
check you know just a nice Queen
sacrifice for for checkmate as the 10th
the black King still controls g2 and
it's just one of those positions that
you don't see every day I mean this
kingdom the King Ganesha tree is just
just an amazing piece yeah a wonderful
game bye-bye young Iranian Grandmaster
ali reza furiosa yeah against 62 year
old English Grandmaster George Pillman
it was a well it was a great win for
Iran but unfortunately Iran lost the
match three to one everyone else lost
against England on board one part amuck
Zulu lost against Michael Adams which
was you know a pretty important game but
here we do have the standings so after
six rounds it's Russia in first place
still from the start with 10 points
India and England tied for 9 in second
we have USA with 8 in China with 6 China
drew today against Egypt as you can see
in 10th place Egypt with 1 point finally
and it was it wasn't really well
basically ye completely blundered a
better position against automatic and
that was enough for Egypt to draw the
game so as you can see and it's not
enough to have to just have Dingley run
on board one you know as even even if he
does reign supreme you know no one can
win a game against him but you know
there are other boards too then Iran
would five in sixth place Kazakhstan
would for Azerbaijan would for Sweden
would for and of course Egypt with one
with the draw achieved against China
today but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I mean I definitely have
it's it's a wonderful game you have your
opponent's king is on h3
the you know the strongest attacking
piece in blacks camp just not in
everyday position and of course I will
most likely use this for as the
thumbnail but yeah I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you are enjoying my short
coverage of the 2019
team championship I would like to thank
high deep David Lander eunsuh dead ski
miles Brown and David Marcus for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content we will be of course
continuing the couple Blanca saga I will
most likely be uploading the subscribers
video in a in a day or two maybe three
you know should have gone out earlier
but you know it's better not to rush
these things
and as usual checking up on your
suggestions so that's it thank you all
and I will see you soon